ということで ものの流れ
時代に遅れる現実離れ上の空ということで
で まあそういうポイントをちょこっと説明してみます
まあこんな感じで この綺麗な波を描けませんでしたけど
回して描いたんだからね
あのものの流れはそうやってずっと流れていく
これはまあ変化しながら流れていく
それで心はこういう風に流れていくんです
なぜかというと 心というのはすごい早いんです
だから同じ時間に合わせてみると
同じ時間時間で 外の世界はこういう風に流れると
心っていうのは随分たくさん
流れてるんですね 刹那で言えば
心はたくさん刹那使っているんです
刹那っていうのは時間のユニットですよ
大体この我々が認識するものはほとんど物質ですからね
目で耳で 鼻で 体で認識するものは全て物質なんですね
で 頭で考える場合は 過去の認識を考えているんですね
あの感情で記録した認識を
で その場合はもう もうまあそれほど時間は流れませんけど
すごい早いんですけどね
妄想は はい 次にループの問題
で ループを作る時 これはまあ論理的なループの場合ですね
ラショナルループの場合ですね
で こうやって認識して
ここで認識したデータをこうやってループ一つ回すんですね
回してまた元に認識することにする
で これからまたこうやってグニャグニャグニャグニャループを回って
この線は本当は同じ線を作ったんですよ
ポイント まあそれは何の意味もないんですけど
一応自分の論理で まあ同じ線で同じポイントで
セクションだけ伸ばしておいたんです
そうやると 今こちらループ 2つ書いてみたんですけど
何かデータとここでデータ取るんですよ
例えばこちらでデータ取る
こちらでデータ取って
なんだこれは？とここでループを回すんです
回して あ わかったと結論に達して
またデータ取るんですね
またデータ取って なんだこれは？とまたすごいグニャグニャのループを回して
こちらもループいくつかありますからね
ループを回して あ そうかと言ってまたデータ取ることになるんです
そこでなんでこちら この青い色でセクション 2つ置いたんでしょうか
その時はデータ取ってないんです
ループの中で忙しいんです
ものは見てないんです
聞いてないんです だから現実をありのままに知るっていうことは
論理型でもできないんです
見たり見なかったりなんです
だから この人のループ
例えばこのループはこちらのデータなんですよ
それでこの間のものは知らないということになっちゃう
何が起きるかとわからない
はい それからこれは論理的なループ
これは誰にでもあります
これは大きな問題ではありません
次に 感情的なループはどうなるのかと
感情的なループは 例えばこちらで何かデータを取る
ここでこうやっていろんな風に回る
この線も同じものですよ
いろんな風に回して回して回して回して
まあ疲れたところでまた認識データ取ったりする
またもうそれに続いてループを回したりする
そうすると その人はちょこっとしたデータ入っただけで長い時間現実離れなんです
自分の殻の中に閉じ込まれているんです
世の中で何が起きているかわからないんです
これは妄想する時の妄想の流れですね
こういう風に心が悪いループもありまして
良いループもあります
で ループ なんかそんな図見てループない方がすごい現実ぴったし知るでしょうと思うかもしれませんだけど
ループ作ることはもうなんて言いますか
避けられません 認識するためにはループは必要ですね
だから論理的なループで認識すればいいんです
それでもデータわからないでしょう
でも構いません 全てわからなくたって
世の中のことは 世の中は持っていくわけじゃないんだから
自分を持っていくのは自分の心でしょうに
だから全部知らなくても大丈夫です
その必要性はないんです
危ないのはこの感情のループなんですね
はい それでまた話に戻ります
次のポイントはこのフリーズすること
心は止まる コンピューターと同じ
変なループに引っかかっちゃうと動かなくなっちゃうんです
怒り 嫉妬 貪欲 落ち込みなどの感情中心にループを作って考えを回転すると
感情が強化して認識は極限に
知識は極限に減るんです
知識は減るっていうことは
同じ知識 同じ知識なんですよ
例えば貪欲で何か見たりして
それで回転すると ただ貪欲
貪欲 結果だけなんです
考えれば考えるほど頭が良くなったわけじゃないんです
ただ好きになってたまらなくなっただけ
何かを貪欲に見たら好きになっちゃう
それで妄想するとどんどん好きになっちゃって
いても立ってもいられなくなっちゃって
頭が良くなったわけじゃないんです
で 知識人なら 例えば舞台の女性を見たら
なんて綺麗な人でしょうかと
頭の人だったら まあすごく綺麗に映ったかもしれませんだけど
まあこれでこれであれで見えたんだから
お化粧洗ったらまあ普通でしょうと
それでも確かめたければ
あの 何て言いますか 司会室
舞台がありますから ちょっと挨拶すると言って挨拶で見たら普通の人間見えますからね
舞台化粧がない あ なるほど
こういう人はああいう風になるんだと
ですから貪欲にはならないんですよ
普通のもう追いかけ追っかけの人が見たらなんて綺麗
これで頭の中で妄想ばっかりふり上がっちゃって
それでポスターまでポスターもインチキでしょうね
それも部屋に貼っておいて
それを見てみて もういても立ってもいられない状態作っちゃうんです
それで知識が開発したわけじゃないんです
同じ知識を回転して強化しただけなんです
だから知識は極限に減るんです
現実は全くも知らない状態になる
どうなるかというと 現実は全く知らない
あの精神的な病気の人々を見てください
現実じゃない 喋っていること
全くも 妄想が重くなるので
心は無知状態に陥る だから知識が出てこないんだから
どんどん無知状態に陥るんですよ
だから妄想イコール無知なんです
妄想すればするほど 無知
無知 無知になっちゃうんです
だから すごく勉強できて鋭い頭の人でも
一旦妄想に入って入って隅ついちゃうと
もうゴミです あの能力は全部なくなるんです
心は硬くなって無知になってしまいます
社会に現実に適応できない状態になる
無知になってくると もう社会にも現実になんにも適応できないんですよ
だから引きこもるしかないんです
引きこもってもできない場合がありますからね
全部汚れてるんだとか
殺菌だらけだとかね いろいろ言うんだから
なんか壁から黒いものが流れてくるんだとか
自分にはね そうするとさらに落ち込む
引きこもって何か体かぶせて隠れるんで
どこかに シーツとか毛布とか何個で
なぜ？なぜそんなことしてるの？いいえ
壁から黒いものが出て
体にこの皮膚から入ってるんだよと
それだったら毛布被っていたっても入りますけどね
悲しいんですよ  そういう患者さんを見るとね
治らないんですよ これがこのフリージング
心が止まったっていうこと
ここは止まりませんよ
ここは止まりません ただ無知になって
そこで硬い状態でぐるぐる回ってるんです
感情が耐える これ感じがおかしいかな
もう耐えきれないので
無知な行動したり 罪を犯したり
ストレスを発散しようとする
この無知状態に陥ると
ものすごく苦しいんですよ
すっごく苦しいんです
例えば子供でも学校には行きたくないと出てくると
楽しいわけじゃないんです
家に閉じ込められてもものすごい苦しいんです
苦しいんだから お医者さんのところに行ったり
カウンセラーのところには行ったりはしますけど
治らないんです アドバイス聞かないんです
妄想のあれできてますからね
データが入らないんです
あなたはそんな黒いもの出ないと言ったってもね
あなた方には見えませんよと
本当ですよ 見えませんだからね
私には見えますよ それも本当です
本人には見える 壁から黒いものが出てくるって
だからどうしようもないんです
幻覚は起こすんですよ
だから幻覚見えない人は幻覚だと言うんであって
幻覚が見える人は幻覚だとわからないんです
だからこの犯罪を起こす人々はみんな感情のループの結果なんです
理性のループでは犯罪は起こりません
たとえ嘘をついたでも感情でつくんです
理性の人だったら この人にこれ言ったら自分が損するんだよと
ですから じゃあこういう風に言えばと
別な言い方で言う 嘘は言わない
で 自己破壊に陥るんですよ
他人を破壊する場合はいくらかエネルギーがありますよ
それでもできなくて 部屋に親が閉じ込めておいたならばね
危ないんだからって そうすると人殺すことはできなくなりますけど
どんどんどんどん自己破壊にはいきます
人格的に退化することも
人生はダメにすることも明らかですね
心が止まったような感じになると
肉体的にも苦痛になります
脳は壊れます 肉体的にも現象が出てきます
すっごくくっつくなっちゃうんです
しかし お医者さんには何の病気も見当たりません
それで普通の元気な人であっても
その病気が出た時は脳MRIを撮ってみるでしょうね
何の問題もないというでしょうね
しかし 時間経ってみれば壊れてます